А вот это у меня после аварии стекло разб
илось упало
и вот после аварии у меня остались появ
ились пигментные пятны.
Это было в 1991 году, или так же, было сначала
после аварии
корочки были, потом эти корочки вроде стали
сходить, но после этого стало
темнее, темнее, темнее, то есть, да, остался
вот после корочек, да-да,
ну вот я сейчас после вашей этих скухота, да
, после ухода это самое, я заметил,
что они меня становились, перестали, да-да,
темнее перестали, даже влейк не дремя.
Истая коронапом, все это жрать?
Я уже считаю, типа, полтора года, ну и даже
не полтора больше, как Задяна проходила.
Ну что, после этого я стала пользоваться, да
, в какой-нибудь веке?
Хорошо, смотрите, чтобы вы висли вот такие
вот пигментные пятны, мы всегда
делаем, что они образовались пигментами
пятны, это не химическое, а механическое
травм, после того, вот такие пигментные пят
ны, то же они на твоей вице.
А почему такая история?
Первую очередь, даже элементально, да, да,
да, да, да, да, да, да, и просто не
целая, да, и с пигантом, да, да, скусовый, мы
объявим лучше, чем образовалась
корочка, або эта корочка выдерживает, да, да
, сначала кожа красно становится, а потом
со временем, кожа, такая коричневая цвета,
вот потом через неделю две
кожи начинается на вице-сетлеем, данными,
так как повреждение было чуть
побольше, да, соответственно, глубокое повр
еждение, и пигантность, скорее всего,
полностью повреждения всем, а кожа начала
догонировать и каким образом, чтобы
максимально защитить от последующих агр
ессивных балкетствий, начинает активно
выделять вот такое выполнение, и если со
временем её не было вести, вот все
данные, наверное, по поводу паскантологии,
в общем, речи нишло, что вот и таким
образом, пигментный пятно бы так вот оста
ётся, чтобы её вывести, примерно процедуру
минимум 6 от 6, да, если все-таки, поцеливка,
по шоковоре, что пигантация появилась,
например,
в течение года, то мы выводим её за одну
процедуру, если в 10, минимальный вот так
то процедуру это может быть 5 и выше, но за 2
и процедуру вы все это пигантация не выв
ести,
потому что мы с агрессивным вазисти, а агр
ессивных слото-интивынгами, мы не можем выв
ести,
то есть если вы захотите быстро вывести пиг
мент непоникатно, вы несёчь комнат,
то есть речи негрессивный пигмент, пигмент
ация вообще все лицо покроет, поэтому можно
девикатно аккуратно выводить пигмент непр
ятно, особенно после химических восьдея и
свитом,
темнические пройтия, сессонное, что,
кажется, поднимажно, то если пизмитация
появилась,
да, более-то так уголка, то вести нужно её
аккуратно девикатно, не по-моему, слышим,
не применяйте к слото-интивынгам, то есть в
случае, что она может помочь,
допил-ти-А-И-У, не это, да и справится, потому
что там есть на кожу киротоз,
киротоз, в первую очередь нужно было допил-
ти-А, немножко облегить кожу старого,
по пигменту, по пигменту собрать, для этого
она нужно делать допил-ти-А-И-У, теперь
допил-ти-А-И-У, здесь вот на крышке
находится сам порошло, отсетляющий и омол
аживающий,
и здесь получается самогелронный экстрот,
а мы перемешиваем геонидурный масса и инц
идан в тиране,
с составе нету кислот, таким образом она не
стимулирует по вторую выработку милонины,
в которой выработки милонины, причем
является пигментаций. Пополуды рекоменда
ции, да, после
пигменты кожа будет немножко отекать, хотя
тут притута с небольшим опоявить на завтра,
и течение 4-5 лет этот пигмент будет рас
ставляться по кожу, это трава, это гималень,
типа, сушенные травы, там никакой микротист
итка, обликосовая кусочка, как хорошо,
прям пересушенная, попадает под кожу и
начинает рассеивать милони, как этот обнов
ляться,
да, вот эта старая кожа с пигментацией
будет обновляться, поднювают выработаться
новая кожа
уже без миланина, и вот таким образом мы
будем сейчас допустим в тиране. Вот с глаз
ами тут
нужно 27 по-другому поработать частот, мы
хотим коже, мы попираем пенку для милони,
пока тоже операционное, верим милонины для
милонины, а именно пенку милонины для
деликатого очищения, да, пости с отмелоком
милонины, а тирсуру может быть в единствен
ной опугации, да,
когда не ханистая возислийся или даже на
контакте выставив, начинает пенится, чтобы
подичку селав, теперь уже начал пенить.
Хорошо, я покажу, конечно, как камеру опуг
ации.
Пенка контактивная с водой идет химическая
реация, и все опять в этой грязь на лице, все
жары растворяются, не просто
наносите пенку в тирать в кожу, то валяется
раздражение. А когда вы как-то перемешете с
водой, идет химическая реация, расшепление,
пен, вы schon в первом вайле, типа, царь. Вайду.
Сейчас дома как важает силу, салантно, пооч
арать. Декратительно, косметик, уже не по, не
искренне, но, да?
Нет, просто не сильно. Только, пожалуйста,
нам и глаза подкрашим все.
Для того, чтобы приимитация еще больше
быстрее начала сиряться, можно локание,
здесь, наносит какие-то поравнувающие тон
ны, ассанции, светляющие именно дневнее, асс
анции, или же кушу.
Я всегда шляпи. Это у меня еще полята, я, ким
Палье, не дашу.
И, конечно, очень важный, так вот, и, защит. А
тем не нужно, или, не длинно, когда жарко,
можно кушать, с маленькой важнее, так, солн
це.
Наше первую очередь, что делать, кожен
начинает, стояться, так, что полезно, компон
енту и последствия у нас, то есть ухоже, так,
после того, как он был про очистили кожу
первую двумя ваней, долго жтать мне нужно,
сразу мы гидем тоннер, данный мы в тоннере
взяла асссетляющий, для пикной петель.
Так, одному надо было, но достаточно, для д
ропавтовой.
Пик, и, им пинненк был опил, да, именно показ
ал, в таком состоянии, то, когда лечу это воз
растный лекошек и плюс, да, лечу это оппон
ентаться.
Она для функциональной ассетляет кожу, и
она важивающая функционер есть.
Если бы захотите взять до опью в ассетляющ
ий, она вот пиннен этот пиннт, ее не пробьет,
потому, что так пинненки маленькие, эффект
будет понимать, эффект будет понимать.
Поэтому не делаем, идеально, например, за 4
дней уже вас вообще лучше царь обновится и
забрение она остановится.
И будет готово восприятие нового обновящ
его компана.
Если бы на растянем ее, в зависимости, все
это и за мной.
А в четвергом, в вторую половине, не а мужам,
по четвергу.
Да, потому, что у меня с утра занятия.
Ага, взяла пидер, а мужа, еще после закрыв
аете, чтобы играть не гонали.
Потому, что взять небольшую посылку, малень
кую взроснцы.
Если появилась эта письма холодная время в
работе, темной, весной, осенью, если в кабин
ете появилась.
Обязательно порядка должен будет пидер,
права, третий, злобную.
Ну, по-моему, наследная жалко.
Это то, чтобы эффективная дефficя произошла.
И пора пером, откроваем, внутри нас и сама.
Ассенция с гелороновой кислотой, с пектид
ами.
И вот именно под крышкой, внутри крышки
получается.
Есть вот сам парашок.
И вот это всё.
И без остатков.
Николй в случае, когда вы будете работать,
препарат мне разделяет, например, целый кат
анон, напала один препарат.
А потом вторую для посвядущего пациента
так делать нельзя.
То, чтобы, для полноцены процедура, вам
нужно использовать полностью весь препар
ат.
Актера целый катарописчет, есть вот одна ам
пока.
Многие-то снатологии жалуются то, что эфф
ект не минимальный.
Но в процессе, когда я начал узнавать,
например,
обычная самая снатолога начинает говорить.
Почему такая проблема?
В целих по-моему, многие, например, попаланы
ее применяют.
Вот этого делать нельзя.
Это одна ампала для одного пациента.
Перемешиваем ее до однородные массы.
Устанавливается система.
И когда вы будете ее набирать, неспоект
ности старайтесь, каждый раз когда выбир
айте, перемешиваете.
Потому что сами головки оседают мясо, а св
ерху остается георонная кислота.
Перемешиваем до однородные массы.
Перемешиваем и начинаем нефтерать.
Правильно.
Кургалуми движения.
Можно вверх.
Водни с удобными движениями назад.
Перемешиваем по часовой против часа.
Временно нужно было максимально втереть.
Больше плавных расходах посмотрим.
Если кольки попадают более 50%, эффект усили
вается.
Если вы будете, допустим, все пациенты
будут в атомной больно.
И вы будете жирить.
Да, пациентку.
С ожиеменными во время дымыки.
А уже либо, когда все пациенко сайк ложится
подушка в реценции.
Если вы не будете, то уже не будет.
Кургалуми, пациентку.
Попробуем в час в стиле.
Кургалуми, пациентку, пациентку.
Кургалуми, пациентку.